the bowler throws the ball the batsman
hits it and Sprint's off but caution is
advised cricket balls can reach speeds
of up to 160 kilometers an hour usually
cricket is played on grass pitches but
here shad Ahmed who captain's the MSV
bouts and cricket team is glad to have a
small gym to play in at least you can
see a lot of people here from Pakistan
from Afghanistan from India and they are
here together to play this game and if
they if they don't have cricket then it
means they have nothing to do
Ahmed and his teammates are proud of
their cricket trophy many of them fled
to Germany just recently now they're
waiting to be granted asylum they rarely
leave their hostel things can get
dangerous outside Ahmed and his fellow
asylum seekers live in bouncing in the
state of Saxony the town has a
picturesque 1000 year old centre but
also a menacing neo-nazi scene in
February unknown arsonist set fire to a
building that was to house asylum
seekers and for two nights in a row in
September a right-wing extremist mob
gathered in the town centre chanting
racist slurs
Ahmed and his friends have experienced
direct threats we met with the almost 40
or 45 boys with black lodges and with
many things in their hands like beer
bottles and bats and daggers they said
go away from here and don't come in the
night because the next time we will not
forgive you and then we escaped
afterwards
Ahmed thought long and hard about
whether he wanted to keep living in
bouncing ultimately he decided that he
would at least for the moment if I will
escape because of sightings again and
again then it will be really difficult
for me to survive myself in this world
Ahmed will not give up just like in
cricket
today his team will play at Czech won a
tough sign to beat it's a complicated
game there are many ways of scoring runs
in cricket bowling the ball and then the
batsman of the other team tries to hit
it as far as possible is just one way of
scoring points or runs as they're called
[Applause]
cricket is a niche sport in Germany last
year some 40,000 asylum seekers from Sri
Lanka Afghanistan and Pakistan migrated
to Germany among them many cricket
enthusiasts and with their love of the
game they've started a real cricket boom
the number of cricket teams has almost
doubled
Foca Ella beck who used to play for
Germany's national cricket team welcomes
this development young ones I find odd
wish Vida better Alf - Dave Karger Club
is benefited super we lost lots of our
top older players and now we've got new
ambitious highly talented players
joining up the Italian tier to loiter
that's what we won the Czech team also
has some South Asian players but they
don't have a steady stream of asylum
seekers eager to play cricket - the envy
of the Czech coach where Angela Merkel
has let everybody in which is maybe
controversial zenman is keeping
everybody out and it's very hard so we
have no refugees they come through the
country they keep coming through to
Germany Ahmed wants to integrate into
German society and hopes that cricket
can break down some of the barriers
local school children and teachers help
Ahmed and his team by scouting suitable
pictures and gyms to play in they also
help organize matches they hope this
will bring cricket players and locals
together the arms will intently our
business we've had people come and watch
a match many weren't familiar with the
sport and we're curious
some people even joined in and played I
think that's a good start
- when your finger doesn't so good on
fun today
MSV bounce and beat the Czech team every
victory makes bounce and feel a little
more like home to these refugees despite
the problems we can have something to
make their lives better and they can a
little bit forget about their problems
which they have faced in their job
and that's it bad hopes cricket will
help bring some normality to their lives
as refugees and maybe even help them
tackle the racism they are confronted
with in bouncing
[Applause]